hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde vor mehreren jahren habe ich
dieses video mit dem titel dieser
website weiß alles hochgeladen und in
dem video habe ich das spiel clever wort
gespielten der clever wird konnte alle
fragen die ich ihnen über mich gestellt
habe richtig beantworten und heute
testen wir ob er das immer noch kann man
daher befinden wir uns hier mal wieder
auf der website vom clever bot ihr seht
schon ich hab mal wieder ein bisschen
mit ihm geschrieben noch mal einfach gut
reinzukommen bisschen so an als würde
ich sagen knüpft mit er jetzt einfach
mal ganz oft locker geschrieben es oft
locker geschmeidig knüpfen als man
einfach ganz entspannt an wir wollen
nichts überstürzen und fragen ihn
einfach wie geht es ihr lieber klamotten
nicht einfach mal depressiv sein was
hast du denn frage ich ihn jetzt einfach
mal ich habe meine spuren
[Musik]
mensch bei dir läuft wohl nicht so
daraufhin antwortet er doch du bist
besonders ok danke dir punkte nach oben
also warum bin ich plötzlich besonders
dumm
ich weiß halt im euro danke dir ja
antworte ich einfach mal mit dem lieben
smiley auch noch kein problem
ja
das wenn ich mit leuten schreibt die
welt eigentlich länger mit denen
schreiben und plötzlich antworten
einfach so ok oder kein problem kein
ding und du denkst du super unterhaltung
ist dann jetzt auch beendet deswegen
stehe ich jetzt einfach einen punkt so
was soll jetzt der blödesten nabu stellt
mir doch eine frage dass alle wirklich
sonst nicht so viel komischer
unterhaltung findest du die schön ich
bin model hast du ja selbst gesagt
antworte ich einfach mal ja und wer bin
ich wer sonst
darauf antwortet jetzt gar nicht leisten
mister worldwide trotz antwortet er
einfach nur darauf ein mann scheint sie
jetzt in die englische sprache ab dürfte
ich würde allerdings sagen dass wir
jetzt erstmal langsam wieder ein
deutscher rübergehen ist es nicht
einfach mal deutsch
das war dein name rückwärts
love oder höhere sprachen lernen da denn
mein name rückwärts ist kult und wie alt
bist 24
liebe frau
ich will mich eigentlich nur ganz
normale total ich würde allerdings sagen
dass wir dieses ganze smalltalk thema
ist einfach mal nehmen und 230 sprechen
von daher frage ich jetzt einfach mal
direkt raus welche das war die frage die
ich auch meinem damaligen video
eingestellt habe welche farbe hat mein
schön wenn er jetzt sagt gelb dann
ich gebe ihm noch eine chance falls
welche farbe hat mein shirt
welche farbe hat mein shirts drei
fragezeichen anderes thema ok ok möchte
nicht welche farbe hat meine rose
vielleicht weiß er das ja woher soll ich
das wissen
telepathie dadurch ob es komplett falsch
geschrieben gründen
schwarz ich fragte ihn einfach mal noch
welche augenfarbe habe ich hab grüne
augen widerspricht meine frage nicht
okay bruders mich nichts gefragt doch
bist du ein mädchen oder ein junge junge
die standardfrage daneben kommen vom
clever aber das hat mir auch in der
letzten videos immer okay
ja und der haltung geändert welche farbe
hat meine boxershorts frage ich ihn
jetzt einfach mal das würde ich mich
auch noch interessieren du hast keine
[Musik]
aber glaubt mir das einfach mal von der
frage ich jetzt auf welche farbe haben
meine socken männer das richtig hat dann
hat jetzt mindestens zwei von 22 von
gibt's erst
wie zuerst ich habe mich noch gefragt
weil jetzt bei mir ist welches socken
farbe trage ich das wort sommerfarben
überhaupt eine welche haarfarbe habe ich
blond vielleicht
die heiße ich lieber bot keine ahnung wo
ich weiß nicht was diese ganzen fragen
plötzlich sollen ok cool name
zurück zu meinen socken welche farbe
wenn meine socken lieber clever motto
[Musik]
guck mal wie gelenkig ich bin als bisher
kann ich den titel noch nicht so ganz
bestätigen ihr habt es ja nur die farbe
meiner hat nur erraten dass ich keine
unterhose aber welche haarfarbe habe ich
frage ich jetzt einfach mal das hat
jetzt mal auch richtig beantworten
trauen das ist falsch
oder ist das braun-weiße nicht könnte
auch wichtig sein er früher hatte ich
eigentlich komplett blonde haare jemand
kindheits bild von mir da war ich
wirklich wasserstoffblond sein vater
aber jetzt hat sich das irgendwie
zusammenbrauen entwickelt und ich weiß
nicht ob ich gut finde oder ob ist
schlecht finde egal frage ich ihn jetzt
einfach mal habe ich einen bart also ich
kenn dich aber natürlich ein risiko ein
was mein habe ich einen bart ich wieder
hinein aber eine okay
ich glaube erst langsam ein gespielt ich
habe nämlich keinen bahn hier glaube ich
unschwer erkennen könnt und ich habe
auch eine schwester also das ist richtig
habe ich noch mehrere geschwister
fragezeichen außer meine schwester ja
ein
mainz jetzt ich habe ein geschwister
oder noch dazu ein geschwisterkind
deswegen frage jetzt einfach mal wie
viele geschwister habe ich dann kann man
das ganz klar
ok
das stimmt hatte ich bereits ein
haustier ja ich hatte ein kaninchen
frühjahr von daher bin ich gespannt wo
ist es so langsam jetzt wieder ein
bisschen unheimlich wo wohne ich frage
ich jetzt einfach mal ich weiß
[Musik]
niemals nein punkt vom punkt wo wohne
ich also ich gebe mal hinter zweite
chancen halt
[Musik]
es ist ein richtig da jetzt gerade bin
ich in köln aber ich habe eine wohnung
in hamburg gekauft und ich jetzt die
tage nach hamburg also woher weißt du ja
wie kann er die letzten fragen einfach
alle durchgehend richtig beantwortet
haben ich frage einfach mal kennst du
congo after weil vielleicht ja deswegen
ja natürlich das ist ein mann
nee das bin ich auch ja klar jeder ist
ein fachkongress da habe ich einen
youtube-kanal frage ich ihnen jetzt auch
mal leider weiß ich nicht das blöd sorry
dass ich hier ab und zu mal falsche
zeichen machen kein fragezeichen aber
ich hatte eigentlich von zehn finger
schreibkurs aber ich kann mich an nichts
davon gehalten habe ich abitur dem ich
jetzt einfach mal als nächste frage
siehst du
was siehst du habe ich habe tour also so
schwester frage ist wirklich nicht mein
schatz die ihr durch die haare wurzeln
wieso soll ich mir durch die haare
wurden meine frage ist ob ich abitur
habe habe ich abitur lieber clever bot
bist du ja klar
nein
ich wollte nur wissen ob ich abitur habe
pumpen
ich liege auf meinem bett ich nicht da
wäre ich aber gerne rad punkt wieder da
schatz du warst ja nie weg bruder ich
würde ihn gern noch ein paar fragen über
mich stellen weil das halt der titel des
heutigen videos ist und ja auch meine
mission so ein bisschen will
herausfinden ob der clever bot immer
noch so viele sachen wie damals über
mich weiß wie groß bin ich frage ich ihn
einfach mal also ich bin jetzt nicht
ganz zwei meter ich bin nämlich 14 90
oder irgendwie so aber es ist schon
ziemlich nah dran das ist richtig
antworte ich jetzt einfach mal man muss
mir auch sein erfolgserlebnis geben ich
weiß zwinkert meinte er ich werde
aggressiv wenn solche smileys kommen
dieser smiley
regt einfach so geisteskrank auf
und auch der hier
man weiß jetzt nicht hey willst du mich
freundlich anlächelt
da willst du mich umbringen und fragt
ihn jetzt noch mal wie viel kilogramm
wie gehe ich also ich wiege irgendwie
glaube ich 84 58 sich tippen dann würde
ich glaube ich nicht mehr leben
als bonbon wie viel wiege ich gebe ihnen
noch eine zweite chance habe ich ja bei
einigen anderen fragen auf gemacht weiß
net doch anscheinend war irgendwie alles
dann plötzlich darauf antwortet
allerdings nur ich bin ein glückliches
mädchen
ok
rad
aber euch einfach mal juhu
ja
wacken
[Musik]
was ist falsch mit dieser website nein
kommt magst du den luca shop.de frage
ich bin jetzt einfach mal warum machst
du mich nicht ich mag dich aber magst du
den lukas frage ihn jetzt ganz nah ich
mag dich auch aber auch meinen shop liga
klar wird also wirklich ich habe sie
noch nicht kennen gelernt sie ist aber
bestimmt im haus so nett wie du
in der luca - shop.de super da lounge am
20 ein tolles neues produkt - chef de
[Musik]
partie shirt mit weißem smiley drauf
20.15 uhr können shoppen soll das shirt
ihr übrigens ein bisschen zerg nödl das
hab ich hatte gestern an und deswegen
lag halt gerade im wäschekorb aber an
bord eine finale frage über mich und die
richtig beantworten kannst dann
dann ist das halt so was ist mein
lieblingsessen
ich habe ein bisschen angst habe ich das
heute allerdings auch ende einer liebe
freunde wenn ich mal wieder luca rede
mit dem thema bord gefallen hat er zeigt
sehr gerne eine bewertung unter dem
video schreiben und in die kommentare ob
ich das öfter hochladen sondern aber
nehmen wir gerne einfach keinen seiner
look to you sei